Chris Hedges how would you define what
you do well I have a good friend when I
work to the New York Times Steve Kinser
who said that I'm not really a
journalist I'm just a minister
pretending to be a journalist and I
think there's a lot of truth in that
explain that I come out of a a very
strong religious tradition my father was
a parish minister for four years I grew
up in the church my mother was a
Seminary graduate I graduated from
seminary although it was not ordained
and I became a journalist but one
doesn't escape that kind of an
upbringing that kind of religious or
theological orientation of the world
where what is paramount is not your
career but trying to in the best way
that you can achieve what would be
defined as the moral life and be willing
to take the cost of that to take risks
that are entailed with that sometimes
physical which I certainly underwent as
a war correspondent
sometimes professional in my own very
vocal criticism in the build-up to this
war in Iraq which finally estranged me
from my employer the New York Times
where I had worked for 15 years did you
leave on your own accord or did they
suggest it too well I was given a I had
given a commencement address in 2003 at
Rockford College in Rockford Illinois
this was a couple weeks after President
Bush had landed on the aircraft carrier
with a mission accomplished banished a
banner and had said in that address
things like this is a war of liberation
but it is a war of liberation by Iraqis
against American occupation I was booed
off the stage my microphone was caught
twice finally at the end of about 17 or
18 minutes young men actually climbed up
on the stage I was escorted off in the
middle of the ceremony by campus
security that became a national story
picked up by right-wing talk-show hosts
people like O'Reilly and others Wall
Street Journal wrote an editorial
denouncing me and I knew what I was
doing I'd been a news reporter there for
a long time I knew that that was kind of
professional suicide and a paper I had
long been vocal and the paper
issued me a formal written reprimand we
were guild which means we're Union and
that's the process by which they give
you a warning a formal warning and then
if you do it again you're removed so I
realized that I had a choice and then I
could pay fealty to my career and muzzle
myself I had been the Middle East bureau
chief for the New York Times by the way
seven years in the Middle East I'm an
Arabic speaker both war and Iraq are not
abstractions to me and but to do so I
felt would be to betray my tradition
betray where I came from betray who I
was and I left the paper and you've got
two books at least right how many books
have you written altogether six I don't
believe in atheists and collateral
damage both this year yes in that I
don't believe in atheists I am quote
here but I believe you said you were
Harvard Divinity stin what year did you
graduate 1983 where you were your
seminary in at any point I was I have
all of the academic work to be a
minister in what Church Presbyterian and
then you say later on in this
introduction that you don't go to church
no they all very rarely why well I have
a very antagonistic relationship with
institutional religion partly because of
the relationship my father had to the
Presbyterian Church he had been a very
vocal supporter of the civil rights
movement the anti-war movement and
finally interestingly enough and a
latter part of his life he died in 1995
the gay rights movement his youngest
brother my uncle was gay lived with his
partner in Greenwich Village my father
had a particular sensitivity to the pain
of being a gay man in America in the
1950s and 60s so he was often at odds
with not only members of his own
congregation but the institution itself
and I you know I I think I quote Paul
Tillich the great theologian who talks
about how every institution including
the church is inherently demonic or as
the theologian Reinhold Niebuhr would
write we can institutions can never
she've the morality of individuals
because institutions are finally about
self perpetuation and and and when
pushed you know that will take
precedence over over moral choice
whereas people can make a moral choice
that is in physical terms of detrimental
even self-destructive have very rarely
probably never happens with institutions
I also you know have a great deal of
problem with the liberal Church my own
tradition I had wanted to be an
inner-city minister so that when I
graduated from college I went to live in
across the street from a housing project
in Roxbury in Boston and ran a church
there for two and a half years and that
made me painfully aware of how the
liberal Church had left the city with
white flight I commuted from Roxbury you
know almost every day to Cambridge to
the garden that is Harvard where people
talked about you know empowering those
they never met you know they like the
poor but they didn't like smell of the
poor and that was a kind of crisis for
me a kind of window into perhaps the
hollowness and even hypocrisy of my own
tradition
so I remain certainly reverential
towards the values and I would say the
religious values that were imparted to
me by great figures not only my father
but you know those icons within our
house Martin Luther King Daniel Berrigan
William Sloane coffin Dorothy Day but
one must also remember that all of these
figures had antagonistic relationships
with the institution's with the
religious institutions that they worked
for so for me there is quite a
demarcation between the religious
impulse and the religious life and
religious institutions which are human
constructs and often use religion and
this is certainly true in the wars that
I covered in the Middle East and the
Balkans use religion for I think very
dark and nefarious ends where do you
live
Princeton New Jersey how long have you
lived there two years already do you
have a family yes three children how old
are they
eighteen thirteen and five months
and where did you grow up upstate New
York in a farm town upstate New York
what year did you get out of Harvard 83
you told me that earlier how long did
you work for the New York Times 15 years
how long have you been gone from the
earth
I left the times I guess it's three or
four years now I've been this book I
don't believe in atheist page 109 I just
want to read a little bit what you wrote
you said the founding myth of the United
States tells its citizens that it is the
duty of the nation to bring
enlightenment to the rest of humanity an
entire historical narrative has been
created to perpetuate this myth the
United States of a Andrew Jackson or
George Washington is not the United
States of Frederick Douglass or Sitting
Bull that we present our history from
the perspective of the winners from
those in power explain that well that is
how you perpetuate a national myth a
myth of creation every nation has it
were not exempt that you know we elevate
for instance and this is you know very
much the currency of our the political
debate today we elevate the founding
fathers who were figures who in most for
in most cases embraced or at least
tolerated slavery the kinds of things
that they wrote to justify the
extermination a campaign of genocide
against Native Americans the the fact
that women had no voice within our
society I mean all of these kinds of
issues don't support that mythic
narrative of us as a virtuous and a good
people and and so it's not told it's
those voices are one confine them but in
the sort of officially sanctioned
narratives the ones that are really at
their core used to promote self
exaltation are you know though those
kinds of truths are painful and
inconvenient and and force us to carry
out a kind of self-reflection or
self-criticism
that in especially in a time of war or
in a time of you know national
solidarity are not only rendered
inconvenient but often shouted down on
June the 23rd and I found this in
something called TruthDig
you have a column that says the hedonist
of power and I want to read you just one
quote and then ask you why you wrote
this we were instructed by the high
priest on television over the past few
days to mourn a Sunday morning talk show
host who made 5 million dollars a year
and who gave a platform to the powerful
and the famous so they could spend
equivocate and lie to the nation we were
repeatedly told by these television
couriers people like Tom Brokaw and Wolf
Blitzer that this talk show host is one
of our nation's greatest journalists as
if in a studio putting on makeup and
chatting with Dick Cheney or George W
Bush have much to do with journalism and
in the next sentence by the ways no
journalist makes five million dollars a
year as you know there was a lot of the
reverse of that on television and in the
newspapers after Tim Russert died a lot
of the reverse of what of that statement
in other words a lot it was you know and
this is has nothing to do with Tim
Russert by the way I you know may very
well have been appalled that had what
followed but I asked somebody who comes
out of the dying tradition of reporting
I think the notion that television
celebrities that what television
celebrities do is equatable with
journalism has been very detrimental to
the health of the news gathering
industry within the United States you
know I often feel especially as we watch
newspapers just sort of implode from the
inside that that the skills that go into
making a good reporter and you know I
was abroad for almost 20 years most of
them were the New York Times I certainly
interviewed heads of state figures like
Yitzhak ravine King Hussein Hosni
Mubarak when I was in the Middle East
Frannie oh - German etc but that's a
very small part of what it is to be a
reporter or to be a journalist that that
it's you know it's a trade it's not a
profession and I think that when you
look especially in Washington at how
celebrity journalism is practiced on
commercial television it is very much I
think courtiers the right word I think
that they are courtiers
they they feed off of their access to
the powerful and the famous and you know
I of stone was right all governments it
really doesn't matter what their
ideological stripe or what party they
you know they come from lie and it's the
job of a reporter to ferret out those
lies to shine a light on areas that
without that journalistic endeavor would
remain dark and good journalists people
like sy Hersh for instance are very
unpopular figures at people in power
don't like them and I and I and I think
that you know and I really here fault
commercial television which has stopped
gathering news largely I think I mean
news is judged solely on its
entertainment value I mean there's been
a terrible terrible corruption in in
commercial news which which and I've
watched it you know when I began
covering the war in El Salvador in the
early 1980s all of the networks had
bureaus the they had reporters and
producers they went out with us I was
working as a print reporter for the
Christian Science Monitor or National
Public Radio they gathered stories they
produced them they reported them that's
vanished it's all gone and it's become
trivia and celebrity gossip and chatter
and you know the noise pollution that
emanates from television and I find
deeply disturbing and I think that that
equation of essentially you know the
world of power and access to power and
with journalism itself has been as
destructive to the health of our
democracy as the equation of
Christianity to the demagogues who
dominate the religious right people like
Pat Robertson
for instance or rod parsley define court
here well a court here is somebody who
has a kind of parasitic attachment to
centers of power I think that's the
article where I described Washington as
a fair side and that's what Washington's
become and and and the court years
extend beyond the press I think most
people in the Democratic Party could be
defined as court years in the sense that
I mean if you look at since the
Democratic Party has taken control of
the Congress since 2006 they have done
little to nothing to defy the the
desires and and and projects propagated
by the Bush White House although they
were clearly elected to do so and that's
where court years do court years you
know there are new class of eunuchs and
and you can find them in the halls of
Congress and you can find them strutting
around the bureaus of the big Washington
networks you also write being a court
here and Obama is the best one of the
best requires agility and eloquence the
most talented of them can be lauded as
persuasive actors they entertain us they
make us feel good they convince us they
are our friends we would like to have
dinner with them they are the smiley
faces of a corporate state that has
hijacked the government and is raping
the nation when the corporations make
their iron demands these courtiers drop
to their knees where to placate the
telecommunications companies that fund
their campaigns and want to be protected
from lawsuits or to remit oil and gas
companies to rake in obscene profits and
keep in place the vast subsidies of
corporate welfare doled out by the state
what do you think of mr. Obama I mean
these explain what you're roasting that
sort of summed it up you can't run for
president of this country unless you
play that game unless you you allow
yourself to become a commercialized
product and Obama is very good at it
he's you know what one of the things
that was fascinating to watch in the
primaries was how he out Clinton the
Clintons but substance there's no
substance
you know watching listening to an Obama
speech is like watching a Pepsi
commercial there's nothing there it's
you know it can be moving it can be
eloquent but you know when you reach out
to grasp anything hard it slips through
your hand you know and I think that you
know one should not pay much attention
to what politicians say in an election
cycle in a campaign one should look at
their voting records and when Obama went
and supported this FISA reform act that
was a clear indication that he was and
is beholden to the corporate interests
who are our shadow government you know
we live in a corporate state and when
you live in a corporate state you
undergo what we have been undergoing
which is a coup d'etat and slow motion
we are being stripped as citizens a
daily of power the FISA bill would be a
perfect example of that you know
however inept or clumsy or dysfunctional
government maybe it is the only
institution citizens have to protect
their interests to safeguard their
interests whether that's through
regulatory agencies whether that's
through public education whether that's
setting mine and safety standards clean
water acts etcetera and when that's
taken away from you when government
works at the behest of corporations then
you as a citizen are completely
disempowered and I think that when you
look at the voting record of Congress
you see how you know it doesn't matter
what we want we may of a you know
seventy something percent of Americans
want to end the war in Iraq but there
are many people many corporations
Halliburton you know Lockheed Martin the
list goes on and on who for whom this
war is a good business and they don't
want it stopped and the voices of the
citizens are irrelevant because the the
entire election cycle the entire
campaign
is hostage to corporate dollars 35,000
lobbyists descending you know like
hyenas on Capitol Hill and and when you
look at the way you know Barack Obama's
voting record on many many many issues
going back and looking at his two years
in the Senate is is one that pleases
corporate backers and and and I think
that that taking a hard look at his
stances and where he stands he's talking
now of course about expanding the war in
Afghanistan as if you know you know
Afghan ease one to be occupied any more
than Iraqis I am you know I'm in a bit
of despair over over where we're going
and and until we break the stranglehold
of the corporate state you know there
are already a lot of people suffering in
this country you know much of my own
family comes from the working class
NAFTA and you know let's be fair the
Democrats have been as bad as the
Republicans on this Clinton's
administration was a disaster for the
working class in this country do you
still have an association with Princeton
I have taught there off and on I was the
ashes fellow and talked in the program
in American Studies but I'm not teaching
this year let me ask you about the
ancho's connection because it correct me
if I'm wrong but Phillip Manchus and as
and and the fellowship that you had he
is that one of the richest men in the
world he'd been involved in oil there's
a caller Aden politically could not
think more differently than you do it's
too late he can't take it away from me
it's already over what was your feeling
about getting paid by the interest money
to do what you did well it wasn't that
much without you thousand it was for a
program of American Studies it was
thirty thousand semester Oh
you know look if you look at the you
know way universities like Princeton or
Harvard have built their endowments you
can hardly pinpoint interests
money I mean it's you know Brown
University was founded by slaveholders
and largely funded by people who
profited off the slave trade I mean you
know you I
I think that I didn't have a moral to
you know dilemma about that did he
well I don't he probably didn't know who
I was he was certainly not on the
committee who selected me and as far as
I know had nothing to do matter [ __ ] I
know he had nothing to do with my
selection as if any money given to
Princeton and in their names
he and his life for on behalf of their
daughters who went to Princeton as I
believe it worked I'm not sure why the
money was but it but the the committee
that selects the Astros fellow says no
you know either or not he doesn't vet
the fellows obviously because I would
not be somebody he probably won teaching
that any of this describe your politics
I found this on Wikipedia by the way
this is about mr. n she's helped fund
Colorado's 1992 amendment a ballot
initiative designed to nullify state
favoritism of gays and lesbians to help
fund the Discovery Institute a think
tank based in Seattle and that promotes
intelligent design and critiques
theories of evolution three supported
the Parents Television Council a group
against television indecency you can see
where I'm going alright so those are all
the things I've spent most of my life
fighting against on the on the other
side of that you're associated with a
nation Institute yes Wayne that the
nation Institute is an appendage of the
Nation magazine and it functions like
it's a left-leaning sort of think tank
or Institute that supports writers such
as myself Jeremy Scahill wrote the book
on Blackwater and Iommi Kline who wrote
Shock Doctrine him before that Road no
logo Brian I mean headed up or funded a
lot by Hamilton fish I don't know how
much ham funds it he runs it but
Hamilton fish is the son of the former
Republican currency in New York and
you're from New York originally upstate
yeah I was a little further upstate them
what I'm getting at is here you have
people all over the lot
parents Republican now they're not and
all that where do you come down at this
stage in your life would you put a label
on yourself and would you would you vote
for I'm gonna vote for Nader part of
that's a moral issue I can't vote for
anybody who doesn't call for an
immediate end to the war in Iraq you
know I have a lot of friends in Baghdad
who've suffered in this conflict the war
under post Nuremberg Laws is a criminal
war of aggression it's illegal we have
no right as a nation to debate the terms
of the occupation we have no right to be
there neither do we have a right to be
in Afghanistan and that was a line I
wouldn't cross I will not vote for a
candidate who doesn't call for immediate
withdrawal this book collateral damage
we haven't talked about yet is dedicated
as Sami al-arian his daughter is
co-author with you on is it Leila yes
Leila al-arian Sami al-arian is you know
sir at least fourteen he's still in
prison yeah explain all that to us and
and whole business of jihad and
supporting the Palestinian fundraising
effort well he certainly did support
he's a Palestinian palate very
articulate Palestinian activist was one
of the first people that Ashcroft
publicly announced as sort of sweeping
up in his dragnet against domestic
terrorism I think the government spent
about thirty million dollars trying to
prosecute him he was acquitted on I
don't have the exact number on most of
the counts and then the jury was hung I
think there was one holdout on two or
three other accounts but he wasn't found
guilty in quite an elaborate show trial
which if you read through the
transcripts can reach a point of a sort
of Kafka ESCO certainty you know playing
transcripts in court of the family
ordering pizza and this kind of stuff I
did plead guilty to a single count of
conspiracy to provide services not in
that trial the government threatened to
retry him again he was financially
broken and you know was the sort of
emotional a deal so he pled for this
lesser account with the understanding
that after serving 14 months he would be
deported so the relationship between you
and his daughter I have that what well I
this book was extremely labor intensive
in that we well I wanted to write a book
where we set out to try and explain to
Americans what was happening to Iraqi
civilians very much focused on or the
you know the the sort of model was the
Winter Soldier film that came out in
we're Vietnam veterans went to Detroit
and film this great documentary where
they talked often with great emotion
about atrocities that they had either
witnessed or taken part in in the war in
Vietnam the security situation is such
an Iraq that you just can't spend
prolonged periods of time with Iraqi
civilians writing about the war from
their perspective it's too dangerous I
don't actually fault the press on this
one and so this was a way to come
through the back door to seek out combat
veterans who would be willing to speak
openly and honestly about atrocities
that they either saw or participated in
and we I wanted a critical mass because
I didn't want the critics to say well
okay there was that incident that was an
aberration or I wanted to expose the
patterns of the war and so over a seven
month period we interviewed often more
than once fifty Iraqi veterans all on
the record and everything was taped
because I didn't want anonymous sources
and if there was any contention about
you know the information in the book I
wanted to reckon all those all those
tapes transcripts were typed out
hundreds and hundreds of pages and it
was just you know I would have spent
three years doing it myself for a book
that I figured not a lot of people would
probably buy it's a very counter
narrative to you know the notion of our
heroes and so that I had not met Leyla
but she was working she had just
graduated from Columbia Journalism
Review and you know very bright and
thoughtful young woman and and so I
asked the nation if I could work with
someone you know to help me sort of
break up the you know tracking down
people willing to talk and breaking up
the interviews and that was the
beginning of our collaboration where
does she live and what does she do she's
now in Washington working for English
al-jazeera and you say in the back that
the Iraqi veterans against the war were
the ones that put you in touch with
these fifty not many of them not all of
them there are actually people we
interviewed who still support or at
least they did when I interviewed them
about Iraqi veterans against the war was
very helpful however you know most
people wouldn't talk it was very hard to
get people to talk partly because it was
so emotional you know that I would
say that in almost every interview that
we carried out there were moments when
these veterans just broke down and wept
you know and I'm not into sort of the
emotional pornography that you know
seems to sort of have taken over
television or commercial television
interviews and so that's when we turn
the tape recorder off and waited for
them to sort of become composed but it
was very very painful and very
courageous because you know these people
you know as you know from reading
through the book not only spoke about
things that they saw but in many cases
spoke about horrible things that they
did when I jump into a specialist Philip
Crystal in the introduction you use him
and we're going to use a fellow by the
name of Lloyd James who is the reader of
the audio book of this let's listen to a
little bit of this and then you can
explain what he's talking about and we
were approaching this one house and this
farming area they're like built up into
little courtyards he said so they have
like a main house common area they have
like a kitchen and then they had like a
storage shed type deal and we were
approaching and they had a family dog
and it was barking ferociously because
it was doing its job and my squad leader
just out of nowhere just shoots it and
he didn't [ __ ] he shot it and a
win in the jaw and exited out so I see
this dog and I'm a huge animal lover I
love animals and this dog has like these
eyes on it and he's running around
spraying blood all over the place and
like you know the family is sitting
right there with three little children
and a mom and a dad horrified and I'm at
a loss for words
and so I yell at him I'm like what the
[ __ ] are you doing
and so the dogs yelping it's crying out
without a jaw and I'm looking at the
family and they're just scared and so I
told them I was like [ __ ] shoot it
you know at least kill it because that
can't be fixed it's suffering and
actually get tears from just saying this
right now but and I had tears then too
and I'm looking at the kids and they are
so scared
so I got the interpreter over with me
and you know I get my wallet out and I
get in twenty bucks because that's what
I had and you know I hadn't give it to
them and tell them that I'm so sorry
that [ __ ] did that which was very
common I don't know if it's rednecks or
what but they feel that shooting dogs is
something that adds to one's manliness
traits I don't know I had a big problem
with that was a report ever filed about
it he asked was anything ever done any
punishment ever dished out no absolutely
not the point
the essence of wars death death is about
the destruction or Wars about the
destruction of all living things all
systems that nurture protect and sustain
life from the trivial to the family dog
to the to the to the grave and serious
murder of children that's what the
reality of war is I spent many years of
my life as a war correspondent and wrote
a book called Wars a force that gives us
meaning was my first book that ass tempt
attempted to implode the myths that we
tell ourselves about war and grapple
with the dark destructive power and
intoxicating effects of violence and you
know that is very much what propelled me
to seek out these veterans and you know
as you can hear all of these quotes are
verbatim and I and I did that on purpose
um you know when you write for the New
York Times you make everyone sound like
they graduated from Princeton and I
wanted to keep this really keep their
voices authentic and real which is why
all the profanity is in there as well
here's another one that has profanity in
it warned the audience in case they
don't want to hear it
it's specialist Patrick Campbell by the
way did you meet either specialist Phil
crystal or a specialist Patrick Hamel
these are these are veterans they're not
in the service now no you know you get
in one of these I I can't remember
whether who I didn't who I didn't often
I think Campbell I interviewed and I
think Krystal was interviewed by Laila
this is under s section and then called
convoys before we play it what's the
purpose so you divide these sections up
with different titles convoy is one of
them what what I wanted to pick out the
flash points of the war in Iraq those
you know moments when Iraqis would come
face-to-face with the occupation on a
daily basis so that would be checkpoints
convoys you know which are ubiquitous
they're freight trains of
they barrel through Iraq Iraqi towns and
cities often at 5060 miles an hour the
soldiers and Marines that we interviewed
all talked about being briefed before
they went into Iraq that they were not
to stop the convoy even if children ran
out in front of the convoys they were to
be run over and they are run over you
know they have to keep moving at all
costs it's dangerous out there
that means driving down the Meridian in
the center of the road often driving
straight into oncoming traffic plowing
into Iraqi vehicles to shove them out of
the way and then of course when an ie D
or an improvised explosive device goes
off near a convoy or crevice troy's a
vehicle within a convoy they lay down
withering suppressing fire with
incredibly powerful weapons belt-fed
saws these are light 7.62 machine guns
automatic grenade launchers 50 caliber
machine guns these are not weapons and
I've seen them all at work that are
designed to be used in densely populated
areas and then of course you know
numerous Iraqi civilians are wounded and
killed and and very rarely is there does
anyone stop to inspect the damage so
convoys are a one of I think the pillars
of the occupation and and and have been
one of those many will probably may be
the most important source of you know
what the military euphemistically calls
collateral damage or civilian casualties
in Iraq how much time have you spent
Iraq well not in this war but a lot of
time in Iraq I covered the Flynn into
Kuwait with 1st battalion 1st Marines
and then was in and out of Iraq for 7
years I mean I was I was covering Iraq
for the New York Times covered made two
trips into the marshes where the Shiites
a lot of time with the Kurds covered the
inspection teams after the war so a lot
of time they Rock here is sergeant I'm
sorry specialist Patrick Campbell you
don't want to shoot kids I mean no one
does said sergeant Campbell as he began
to describe an incident in the summer of
2005 recounted to him by several men in
his unit but you have this I remember my
unit was coming along this elevated
overpass
and this kid in the trash pile below
pulls out an ak-47 and just decides he's
gonna start shooting and you not
understand when he Oh spent nine months
in a warzone where no one every time
you've been shot at you've never seen
the person shooting at you and you could
never shoot back here's some guys some
fourteen-year-old kid with an ak-47
decides he's gonna start shooting at
this convoy
it was the most obscene thing you've
ever seen every person got out and
opened fire on this kid
using the biggest weapons we could find
we ripped him to shreds
sergeant Campbell was not present at the
incident which took place in cadmium but
he saw photographs shown to him by
members of his unit and her descriptions
from several eyewitnesses everyone was
so happy like this release that they
finally killed an insurgent he said then
when they got there they realized it was
just a little kid and I know that really
[ __ ] up a lot of people in the head
they'd show all the pictures and some
people were really happy like oh look
what we did and other people were like I
don't want to see that ever again
would you get this I mean this is this
story's being told negatively because
the fella doesn't like it would you get
a different story if you talked to
people who were for the war no because
anybody who's been through combat is
gonna tell the team same stories it's
how you rationalize it afterwards that
matters and I think you know and I found
this I mean that there were on a candle
you know because there were 50 people I
can't I'm not always great with the
names but one of the most devastating
stories we uncovered was told by a guy
who supported the war but the reality of
combat is venal and brutal and dirty and
if you come out of that reality the
stories are the same
what would you can imagine people
listening saying oh this guy's anti-war
and he sounds like he's maybe not even
for America he doesn't like the history
of America and all that what if you
found your sister by asking first what
do you think of the United States
I think that the country that I grew up
in and and cherished and loved and
honored is being destroyed if you were
in the White House and you had been
there during 9/11 we've talked a lot
about this they'll need to go off on all
the war stuff but what would you have
done what would have been the legitimate
thing from your perspective to do if you
had 3,000 people who had been killed
well I covered al-qaeda for the New York
Times right after 9/11 I was based in
Paris and I covered al-qaeda in Europe
in North Africa um terrorism is a tactic
it's been with us and solaced wrote
about the jakar thern wars it will be
with us as long as the human species
inhabits the planet the only way to
fight terrorism is to isolate terrorists
within their own society after 9/11 we
had gathered the empathy of the world
including the Muslim world Muslims and I
was there or appalled at what had been
done in their name and in the name of
their religion senior clerics including
Sheikh tantowi the Sheikh of al-azhar
the chief Sunni Islamic University in
the Arab world immediately denounced the
attacks of 9/11 as a crime against
humanity which they were and then went
on to denounce Osama bin Laden as a
fraud somebody who has no theological
training no right to issue fatwas or
religious edicts if we had had the
courage to be vulnerable if we had
realized that that empathy was our
greatest strength and our greatest asset
we would be far more secure and safer
than we are today
instead we sided to speak to the
terrorists in the language in which they
spoke to us which is a language of
violence and we began dropping iron
fragmentation bombs all over Afghanistan
in Iraq and what we did is essentially
resurrect a movement that had been
within the Islamic world pushed to the
margins and that is the great tragedy of
our response to 9/11 you have a note in
your book about
GSA study that was between the years of
2003 and 2006 where we as a country have
spent 31 million dollars in Silesia
that's the way you pronounce it it's
it's sunless in both Iraq and
Afghanistan twenty-five hundred dollars
for a death fifteen hundred dollars for
serious injury two hundred dollars for
minor injuries have you been able to
follow up on that since 2006 and what is
this all about
well that's money that's sort of doled
out you know when families you know for
instance if in Afghanistan a wedding
party is killed in a way that they seek
to make amends system is to give
payments to surviving family members
what's the reaction when people get
these payments well the reaction of any
father or mother who's had a child
killed who has some stranger from
another country who doesn't speak their
language or understand that culture come
and drop a bundle of currency on their
lap and walk away you know what would be
our reaction you know we the tragedy of
the war in Iraq and Afghanistan
is that we are the most potent and
effective recruiting tools the
insurgents have I mean that's why we see
a resurrection of the Taliban we're now
in a period in its world where people
are saying we want the surge worked your
reaction to that we may we've made a
pact with the devil in Iraq by buying
off the Sunni insurgents the so called
awakening groups there are eighty to a
hundred thousand Sunnis with a lot of
American blood on their hands who now
receive salaries from taxpayers of three
hundred dollars a month our tax payers
yeah who have been allowed to ethnically
cleanse their little fiefdom xand
enclaves in Iraq pushing out primarily
Shiites who have no loyalty to the
central government a week's you know
shiite-led and central government and
who are biding their time you know the
by allowing you you know the Sunnis to
come out of the shadows and create a
kind of conventional force in over the
long
is extremely dangerous because the
Sunnis dominated Iraq under Saddam
Hussein they constituted most of the
officer corps all of the intelligence
units and all of the special forces and
elite units they have the wherewithal
organizational capacity and training to
create a very potent and lethal force
within Iraq so it's bought us time now
you know the surge most of the troops
that were deployed in the search were
primarily in Baghdad Baghdad is no
longer a unified city Iraq is no longer
a unified country the the experiment
that was Iraq and the breakup of the
Ottoman Empire is gone and is never
coming back
Iraq is just a warren a labyrinth of
blast walls separating Shiites from
Kurds from Sunnis who you know and
everyone swaddle lob mortars back and
forth it's a mess it's not sustainable
and I think that you know unfortunately
because of many factors not least of
which is the security and the expense
I'm the wars not reported American
Journalism Review did a story a few
weeks ago where they looked at air time
devoted to the war in Iraq it's down in
the single single digits I think 3 or 7
percent especially in this is especially
egregious coming from the cable news
networks that sold us the war in the
first place so the notion that the
occupation is somehow sustainable is a
very dangerous one because it will lead
us I think down we have two roots in
Iraq one is either we begin and orderly
withdrawal or the mission collapses that
those are the only two and if the
mission collapses it's chaos here's
another reading from Lloyd James who
reads the audio part of your book it's a
specialist
Abby Pickett and this is in the section
it's about not engaging with kids when
you get into the end let's listen to
that and you can explain it civil
affairs projects were minimal poorly
organized scattered and sporadic
veterans said we should have done it on
an enormous systemic scale not this
anecdotal are we up to school here and
we help to school there and it's great
No
talking about that said sergeant
Flanders you know I hear veterans say
that and I want to call [ __ ] on it
he continued because the problems of
Iraq and their magnitude far outweigh
the tiny stories that one veteran can
say I can tell you about the vast amount
of school supplies that my unit helped
coordinate to have shipped over from our
families and we passed it out to a local
school yeah we did that
who cares on the other hand 99.99
percent of the time we were not engaging
with these people
we weren't helping him at all we might
hand out coloring books and pencils to
kids at the schools during the day
specialist Middleton said but that night
we were arresting their older brothers
and killing their dads so it just seemed
kind of pointless hearts and minds
chapter a lot of people say who are for
the war that the media is not reporting
the good stuff that they're doing you're
suggesting that this only happens about
1% of the time well that's I think most
all of the veterans we interviewed
suggest that it only happens about 1% of
the time the only language that we
really speak to Iraqis is the language
of violence we don't have the linguistic
cultural historic social literacy to
speak any other language in Iraq and
what that does is create to polar
extremes you know if you know when you
speak in the language of violence it
always fuels the two extremes I saw that
in the Balkans you know that the
dictator of Croatia Franjo Tudjman
needed in some perverse way slobodan
milosevic and Belgrade had just as
Bulow's Milosevic needed to Sherman and
these extremes play off of each other so
that al-qaeda needs a George Bush just
in many ways as you know to build his
agenda and his imperial project Bush
needs an al Qaeda and and they both
inflate and elevate the other and they
both create a kind of death spiral where
the center and you remember Iraq where I
spent a lot of time
is or at least was largely a secular
country with a highly educated middle
class a very high standard of living
you know women were not repressed the
way they are in Iran or the way they are
in Saudi Arabia it was in many ways I
mean certainly and you know one thing
the Bush administration did say
correctly was Saddam was as bad as they
said he was I mean and I you know I've
stood over the mass graves of 1,500
bodies when the Iraqi troops withdrew
from northern Iraq after the war I mean
I've seen it but this was a state above
perhaps all states in the Middle East
that was best situated a positioned to
make that leap forward into a modern
functioning you know if not democracy
certainly a modern functioning system
that could work
did you ever meet Saddam Hussein no what
was your reaction when he was executed
lied I I don't believe in the death
penalty so I mean I would have preferred
that they just lock him up forever you
know he is Saddam Hussein was you know
his tyrants go he was right up there I
mean he he you know was somebody that I
certainly would have kept behind bars
for the rest of his life the two
principal candidates for president mr.
Obama mr. McCain are both for going into
Afghanistan even increasing the number
of troops there what do you say to that
big mistake why because the Afghan East
don't want to be occupied any more than
the Iraqis what do you do back to you
kinda if+ different problems the Taliban
primarily and it's that fusion of the
Taliban and al-qaeda which has taken
place largely in Pakistan
the only way to fight terrorism is is to
turn it over into intelligence agencies
and I think one of the reasons that we
reacted after 9/11 the way we did is
because of gross intelligence failures I
was working in Paris and you know
several times a week seen the most
senior French intelligence officials who
at least at that time were far advanced
in terms of their understanding of
Islamic groups they were the only
intelligence agency that I knew of that
actually had human assets inside of
al-qaeda it's how they stopped the Paris
embassy bombing plot for instance so I
think it's a two-prong no one of course
you know it is that slow and laborious
building of effective intelligence
services that can penetrate and
understand these movements and then
ultimately break them apart and that
takes years as we saw with the Israelis
after Black September you know it took
them two years to hunt these people down
and then you have to alleviate and this
comes through aid programs relief
programs alleviate the despair the
desperation the rage that goes into
creating people who are willing to be
human bombs you know I spent a lot of my
life in Gaza and you know I have watched
I first went to Gaza in 1988 and I have
just you know when Hamas by the way it
was a marginal nonentity it was as a
matter of fact in roundups they would
let the Hamas people go because they saw
them as a nice way to break up the
control of Fatah run by our fight the
Israelis and I've watched the Israelis
make blunder after blunder after blunder
and essentially empower the very radical
movements that they're trying to break
and and you know one has to have a great
deal of cultural understanding in order
to in and of course it's very
Machiavellian but I mean in order to
essentially break apart these groups if
you if you go in with just a big
truncheon you're just dumping fuel all
over the fire
you know the situation in Afghanistan if
you take there are roughly 50,000 NATO
troops half of them are American you
know soldiers and Marines are dying at a
faster rate given the numbers that are
there
in Iraq we have seen now the transfer of
the tactic of suicide bombs which were
non-existent before December 2005 in
Afghanistan being transferred to Iraq I
mean - from Iraq to Afghanistan so you
know I think just as we resurrected
al-qaeda the prolonged occupation of
Afghanistan is resurrecting the Taliban
50 interviews with former soldiers and
Marines and and were it audio or video
tape audio where is it where you gonna
put it all well I have it all I mean I
have it all typed out and then I have
the audio available for anybody to
listen to any website they put they put
some of the audio up on the publisher
put it up on the website
but you know the problem is it's so
often so meandering that we pulled sort
of you know I think as you did here some
of the most potent stories or anecdotes
this is the nation books which is is
that a Perseus group yes and here's
another soldier sergeant Camilo is it
Mageia Mejia should be a Spanish name or
a mej I a sergeant Mejia recounted an
incident in Ramadi in July 2003 when an
unarmed man drove with his young son too
close to a checkpoint this is under the
checkpoints chapter and what's that
about what's the checkpoints chapter
about well again it's one of another one
of those flashpoints checkpoints you
have fixed checkpoints around government
buildings and our Imperial City the
Green Zone and the super bases but
oftentimes you have checkpoints they
called flying checkpoints that are put
up for a few hours and Iraqis who don't
you know I've never seen a checkpoint
there before will they drive too quickly
they don't break fast enough or they're
a Sunni in a Shiite neighborhood and
even though they see people in Iraqi
army uniform that doesn't inspire
confidence because they and so they've
try and run the checkpoint or to go
reverse and they get they get shot I
mean the the numbers of Iraqis who get
shot I mean you know any any car that
that is perceived by American soldiers
approaching checkpoint as a
was fired upon sergeant Mejia says the
father was decapitated in front of the
small terrified boy by a member of
Mejias unit firing a heavy 50 caliber
machine-gun quote by then said Mejia who
responded to the scene after the fact
this sort of killing of civilians had
long ceased to arouse much interest or
even comment the next month Mejia
returned stateside for a two-week rest
and refused to go back launching a
public protest over the treatment of
Iraqis he was charged with desertion
sentenced to one year in prison and
given a bad conduct discharge troops
were rarely held accountable for
shooting civilians at checkpoints quote
better to be tried by 12 men than
carried by six unquote was the
prevailing attitude court-martial a rare
occurrence was infinitely preferable to
possible injury or death what happened
to Sergeant Mejia after he was
discharged he had was it a dishonorable
discharge yes where is he you know he
lives in Florida and he is I think he
runs or is one of the directors of Iraqi
veterans against the world
in your opinion did he do the right
thing yeah well he exhibited physical
courage is something you see on a
battlefield very rarely do you see moral
courage and he exhibited moral courage
he was came back with his unit and
refused to carry a weapon even though he
was a sergeant in the army and you know
it is those acts of moral courage one
thinks of the helicopter pilot for
instance at me why who the 28 year old
pilot you know who had children of his
own who landed his helicopter to protect
I think was four or five Vietnamese I
mean it's extremely lonely and difficult
to stand up among the camaraderie of
troops and denounce a wrong as a raw and
I have tremendous respect for kamila
what is it what there's all this done to
your life I mean you're a very critical
of a lot of journalists you're critical
the war critical of the country and all
that do you find yourself persona non
grata in places that used to be greeted
with open arms because you work for the
air time well as a reporter you know
when I came back from overseas my one
nan
vegetable demand was don't send me to
Washington I don't really want to go to
the White House I never wanted to be a
State Department correspondent I never
wanted to follow a public official
around with a tape recorder and stand
behind a rope and that was never the
kind of reporting that I did that even
when I covered in the first Gulf War the
war I was always out I don't think most
of my time was with the Marine Corps I
very rarely interviewed somebody above
the rank of sergeant you know I you know
I'm very much an on-the-ground reporter
I very much see for me the the best of
journalism is to give a voice to people
who without my presence would not have a
voice George Bush doesn't need me to
have a voice so the the people that I
care most about and the people that I
sought to write about as a reporter
don't consider me persona non-grata
people like camilla Mejia would I think
argue that it's good that there are a
few of us out there because without us
the stories and and and and the courage
that he and many others exhibited I
think most of those exhibited in this
book remember this was you know this was
a real act of courage on the part of
these veterans to get up and speak like
this you know wouldn't have had a venue
gonna close this with a audio clip of a
suicide note and the gentleman's name is
Colonel Ted not sure how you pronounce
it with who zing West who zing I've only
read it I don't know how to pronounce
why did you open your book with this
because at the time he was the
highest-ranking officer to die in Iraq
and he died at his own hand apparently
he had been one of the most respected
professors of philosophy I believe
ethics at West Point he was a man of
great s from all I've read and people
spoke have spoken with the new him of
great personal integrity and courage and
he was appalled by what he saw around
him when did he commit suicide the date
is in there I think it's 2004 - well was
it was he there was he here was it an
error he was there in Iraq
yes he's working for General Petraeus
doing what you know
he was working he was overseen contra he
did several things I think but his last
job as I understand it was that he was
overseeing contractors and he was
appalled at the fraud and theft and
waste and abuse of on the part of the
contract what was the military's
official reaction to what happened to
him the suicide well the military ruled
it a suicide there are family members
and others who raise questions about you
know whether because he was very
critical of the abuse carried out by
contractors whether you know he was
killed but I think it still officially
remains a suicide
here's Lloyd James reading and Chris
Hedges we thank you for joining us
thanks Rob